energy
hello welcome back to Dead Space we just
got the ads up and running
whoa whoa hey what the where I just oh I
didn't reload
scared of me you scared me yeah you
should be I definitely wasn't scared of
you that's for damn sure
should I put it back in water
purification probably not it's locked
or whatever I guess that's fine
it's probably for the best
oh oh no no no no
yeah no thank you
you know thank you guy
no thank you tall
okay
great good to know now that I got ads
done I don't exactly know
oh I don't exactly know where I'm
supposed to be going oh yeah Medical
right the message from Nicole definitely
not an old one because last time I was
at Medical it did not seem like a
sanctuary
it really didn't seem like a sanctuary
oh okay so where am I at oh
oh 20 000 though oh this might be a bit
close on the budget oh I'd have to sell
that oh
but I don't wanna
oh but I don't have enough why did I buy
so many nodes
oh well
who needs this ammo not me
who needs this health not me
this will be worth it it'll definitely
be worth it it'll 100 be worth it and I
can promise that and I can assure that
because I have confidence and maybe not
actual correct information but I got
confidence and that'll carry a foreign
life
Theory
there we go now I see some armor plating
on there
hell yeah
oh yeah
oh now that's what I'm talking about
okay I'm poor but
I am armor Rich so you know there is
that
still hearing a lot of Whispers
but good thing I killed everything over
here and there definitely won't be
anything to try to kill me I should also
heal but will I
will I heal I bet you're on the edge of
your seats just waiting to find out if
I'm gonna heal or not
so if I just go back
to Medical
I do not need to oh yeah you're in crew
Hammond why are you in crew doesn't make
a lot of sense there there probably were
also some
like
mining locked there probably were also
some level two security doors back there
that I could probably go to but I know
that there are level two ones in medical
specifically and what that means is I
can get some extra goodies
and then I won't be so poor
which I am
poor
good
what you said the chemical lab
I can I can barely hear you
you're losing my signal
interesting
[Music]
well these are different vibes okay
fascinating
ah I see I see
um so what kind of a sanctuary were you
talking here Nicole
um
cuz oh hi
how are you this looks wait a minute why
Daniels
the door to Medical just locked behind
me hello
I have a feeling I might need a big boom
I don't have the big boobs
you'll be safe here I'm a doctor oh is
Nicole Brenna with you
you're not here for Sanctuary then
welcome Dr Ben is currently engaged
shall I send you to her how about you
unlock these doors and I'll find her
myself
are you that selfish
you might have something in
[__]
so
you've decided to be difficult
take a seat
I'll deal with you momentarily
okay whatever you say oh I think I need
to I do have it on me right yeah I do I
just need to quickly equip it it's gonna
be in four for the big Kabooms
who's gonna be here with me
who is it
I'm gonna heal yeah healing healing is a
good idea
ah
so you're gonna be with me momentarily
right
well that was goopy hero jelly it works
I don't want hero jelly oh that sounds
awful all right well I'm kind of tired
of waiting I don't know if anything
would actually happen if I was gonna
wait around all this time but uh about
the so-called Sanctuary that you're
talking
um
can I find it myself
big Kabooms ready to be delivered
oh you don't need a big
nicely nicely handled me
with me
God damn I'm good
hey wait this is locked too oh
okay
fascinating
hello
oh
um
research
I'm so close to finding that missing
Factor
a unitop just would understand
uh-huh
oh
um well ha oh oh
you oh man what's oh that that don't
look good
um
oh
I'm glad I have a helmet on okay
well I should probably blow that up
definitely probably uh
whoa
are you uh one of the well oh oh right
right oh oh good great good oh great oh
wow I'm gonna get the big Kaboom out for
you
is that
oh did I get it
no no not that one
why are you doing this to me
won't poop out anymore
stop
well that was awful
um that was horrible to witness Matt's
gonna stay with me for a long time
uh
gross
okay
um so
whole
horrifying
can I open these
yes I can
thank you
it's not much but it's something I guess
okay so now that I got that nightmare
out of the way I can't wait to find out
what other nightmare I'm gonna find
what does the main fire of this do
ah a continuous beam of way
you want a continuous beam of
[__] you energy
[Applause]
what are we talking about oh there you
are
all right
hey maybe this thing ain't so bad maybe
it's pretty good but I should probably
still just use the secondary fire
because I need to hit things really
really hard
but there's nothing in here because I
fell down
that's still a bloody mess
okay
I could uh change it from the elevator
but there was something there I think
I'm supposed to oh no I am supposed to
go up okay let me pop in here real quick
oh wait no I've already been in here I
need to get to the chem lab eventually
but I I guess I gotta go the long way
around
[Applause]
oh
whoa oh my God
foreign
good stuff man this fleshy growth is
just really doing something for the
place aesthetically
gorgeous
good great
very good very great
oh so zero g therapy I don't think
that's where I'm supposed to be going I
hope yes it is
but what was over here in the
observation nothing still
oh new unless I missed it
Retreat there
I have to record these days
um the old memory you know
as I was saying the new treatment I'm
developing should be just a ticket the
trial is very prolific it's trial uh
you'll be back at your post in the Jiffy
with easy none the wiser unless
you don't trust me no of course I trust
you
Let's uh give it a shot
yeah let's give it a shot
yeah I'm sure it's gonna be great
oh boy
that sounds good
I expect death within the hour but it
changes to the vascular system are very
promising
one moment for the cleanup
for the last time get a trauma team in
here
yes I called three times my patient is
crashing get off your smoke break and
help me
uh-huh oh wow good acting very intense
I feel like we're all in good hands
probably
sorry ah cryogenics huh well I don't
know if there was anything in 0g that I
needed again
like maybe there was a security door let
me just quickly do a down and back
oh oh never mind
that's what I like to see
yes please yes please yes please yes
please oh I don't even know what that
was but I love it
line rack
I didn't get a line rack what does that
mean
I don't know what any of that means but
it sounds cool
chemical research lab great
another node
well ain't you just splendiferous
wonderful
uh-huh
there you go I can get back that way now
I think yep
yep I sure can
whoa
cool
I lost survivors
please
uh
your medical officer Nicole Brennan
interesting surprise transmission
override Isaac oh just a trick
Isaac
hey wait a minute
all right
Dr Brennan's nearest and Dearest
we were colleagues you know
Dr Charles
are you the reason
the marker won't begin
that's uh
convergence is installed
and she's meddling
how is the question
but even if I was to ask
I suspect
you're not the talkative
and I haven't fully explored the cause
of death as that missing Factor
this microwaved
now I think
you're on the right track there
try and relax Mr Clark
convergence is so close
Maybe
your death
will tip the balance
what is your stasis last so long I feel
like that's not fair I feel like you
know my oh
oh hey what's up bud okay how about a
big old kaboom
oh you don't listen
I blew you to hell hell I win ah good
fight yo
I'm going it's not is it oh that way
thank you
I'm leaving goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
I'm leaving sorry everybody here uh whoa
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa bad time bad
time bad time for this bad time for this
not not what I need right now
oh God okay well we gotta get going we
gotta get going we gotta get going we
gotta get going we gotta go go go go go
go go go go we gotta get going uh you
know what I say about this
I have another one just in case
ah
good thing that lasts so long
broadcast
oh God every way out is locked down to
one of the offices must be mercerous I
can vote Force the internal doors but
you will have to reach his office and
list the lockdown manually
oh okay how do I do that
I'm Gonna Save I like saving
okay so I gotta go over there let me
just yeah I got time for a little
shopping I'm sure that thing's not gonna
come after me I'm sure I'm perfectly
safe here a lot of the okay line racks
okay well I don't have the thing that
that's for
eign
[Music]
but he takes an attack like that first
ah
good
I mean isn't that the point it was
personal when I did it
is what I'm trying to say hey stop whoa
what was that
God that wasn't what I wanted this is
what I wanted either
whoa whoa whoa whoa hey whoa good God go
oh my God go
foreign
oh my God what's hitting me
okay hold on here whoa whoa
whoa I might be almost dead okay wow I'm
alive
okay this is not great
oh boy oh that's not good okay so can I
run running would be delightful
oh there's got to be something I can
rust at him hey
whoa baby where'd you come from
oh boy that's not good
you hate to see it
run run now
just need to get a second so I can
no not that nope not that get in get in
get in get in get in oh my God I don't
know if there's a way to go but I'm
gonna go
oh boy I'm out of ammo
oh boy I'm out of ammo I only have big
boomy oh what is it
oh really this is unfortunate timing for
me huh and you
come on no
how are you not dead
how are you not dead I do not understand
that I didn't mean to do that I am out
of ammo
oh boy please don't
come on
oh what did I just do I muted it how did
I what how did I mute what what I have
no ammo I gotta Stomp the crap out of
you guys
I'm gonna stomp you
I how did I mute what did I press to
mute what oh there we go my God
okay well I couldn't hear anything for a
bit there well that was unfortunate and
I am just so extremely out of ammo this
is about as bad as it could possibly be
this is going horribly okay I got
something in the pulse rounds
I'm gonna have to load up on ammo next
time I've been spending too much money
on these upgrade things I haven't been
doing anything for my actual ammo when I
need it
perfect I'll read this okay uh that
that's what you're writing down this
down the truth will thank me later I
hear it too Mr Harris others find the
markers signal a burden but for me it's
inspiring new surgical techniques new
technical designs a Pity I can't grasp
the deeper nuances like you do page
generis you mean the codes or the voices
that are hungry to be heard hungry like
the stars are hungry and I think those
fools tried to cure you you have a
divine
you have a Vine insight Mr Harris I can
interpret it the deepest secrets of the
marker convergence even the hive mind
itself could be ours if you trust me God
speaks through the marker it needs to be
heard but I can't give it to you I try
but it Slips Away like it's stuck behind
my eyes and the best means to retrieve
it would be have unfortunate
consequences and less tell me Mr Harris
do you know the term cellular
regeneration
I don't I'm just an engineer with no
ammo but I do have some stasis which is
very helpful
good credits that's what I need well
technically I do need that but at the
same time
I don't like that I need that okay maybe
maybe oh yeah yeah oh next thing I'm
going to load up on oh Dr Mercer's
office perfect
oh
love what you've done with the place
oh you okay
you don't look okay
but that's been deceiving in the past
so uh
at least read this real quick
convergence where the bodies of the Dead
will rise United undying made whole by
the marker so we're taught but all this
raw material all my work and the marker
remains inert ever since that first
Contact as it were words repeated in my
head the makers must be absorbed a
Divine inside perhaps that creating my
hunter is part of the answer and yet I
deleted no I will not doubt no
unitologist has ever been so close to
cheat death that withered old Tyrant I
must have a matching tenacity
right
because of course are you all right
are you okay
huh
how much health I got
it'll do
good morning
local dual protocol is corrupted
rebooting system please stand by
stand by for what oh no
oh hi hold on I can help you
not me save Hydroponics
we're all dying there's poison but
there's still time her enzyme will work
if not
good she just needs liquid nitrogen
save us
[Music]
someone translate what that says
does he have to be right oxygen
I came looking for liquid nitrogen and
there has to be some in the cryogenic
slab okay not like we have a better
option I'll clear you with Pastor crail
thank you I appreciate it
thank you for your patience okey dokey
then did you make him real fast and
Slammy okay I'm gonna go now
I'm Gonna Save again just in case oh oh
I don't like that
oh
let liquid lick oh God oh God oh oh God
I should have saved my ammo oh God oh
God oh God oh God
oh
God I'm dead
oh man
oh God I can't breathe
well there's a bit of a problem
only a slight bit of a problem
oh well that's unfortunate why is that
happening no no no
no
well I'm not doing good I really hope
there's some air down there and if I got
an air
oh hey
uh man this is on wow why
just stay there stay there oh my God I
can I please move
oh man I'm gonna go in here
oh wow you're slow was I supposed to go
in here I was not was I was Aussie eye
just ah please don't oh boy wow this is
unfortunate oh my God I'm in trouble oh
what do I have left what do I have left
one big last boom
I have so
I have so no Health please elevator
please elevator please
[Music]
okay let's see no ammo here
16 bullets
that's all I need
that's all I need that's all I need oh
please oxygen anybody anybody oxygen
oxygen yes oh well well there's a
problem what was coming behind me I
don't know let me listen to this
tissue regeneration experiment five
these children of the markers
please please no don't worry if it's
been still alive
oh no wait
oh this ain't good
oh boy
um
well there's a problem uh
oh yeah Emergency Equipment no wait I've
got a chance for equipment
what oh there oh this I must have missed
that on the way out
well get ready Buster you're about to be
busted
please tell me you can't come in here
also but I need kind of oxygen is that's
a bit of a problem okay all right I got
something I got something I don't know
what I got I don't know if I'm holding
it I better I really hope I'm holding it
I really hope I'm holding it
okay gotta get some oxygen
oxygen
yeah
okay I don't know what I'm doing here
what am I doing here I don't know I
don't know what I'm doing
[Music]
oh I went the wrong way again
God I don't even know if I'm going at
all the right way
I'm looking for cryogenics and I don't
know where the hell that is
there no it's not
what
but but but but but but but but but but
but
stop the poison gas how how do I how do
I oh
okay it's clearing Versa pumped that gas
in from Hydroponics
because the Air's already that bad
I'll open the other door from the
chemical lab it'll take you straight
there okay well that was just super
duper
I'm Gonna Save
I like saving bet you didn't think I was
gonna make it bet you were all banking
on me biting the big one
but I didn't I showed you I'm a Survivor
I'm a Survivor who is now going to stock
up on a lot of ammo
if I can
I kind of can
uh
these are targeting it's just a bigger
version of the plasma cutter right I
don't need that even though I
technically have the ammo for it I don't
need it I don't need that and I don't
need that I need Irmo
a lot of it
like all of it
I need ammo
thank you
that'll do
that's what I like to see I should have
been doing it before but I was not
so now
I get to survive Maybe
okay
but what is in the research Wing was
there a uh if there was a level two door
here I do want to go find it because I'm
at least there is this
I almost didn't think I got that
because I need to find health I need to
find literally anything that could help
me and if there's a few doodads that are
going to come try and kill me that's
also good because maybe they'll do well
down wow
I thought we did this already
I thought we did this
oh great
thank you
oh God give me something
baby
get stomped
get stomped get stomped
oh my God what
oh God what is that
give me that
ow
yes please yes please yes please medpack
this is exactly what I was looking for
oh you're oh you're a different one
[Applause]
are you burned
okay did I do it
did I win
are you down there oh it's a baby
all right
okay well I sure am glad that I came
here actually I am because that gave me
the health that I needed but also it
chewed up some of my precious precious
beautiful ammo the ammo that I cherish
and love with all my heart
and if it's willing to compromise my
beautiful beautiful ammo
stand for that
I won't stand
okay this is Brennan's lab I don't see
any level two security things here
probably aren't but you know
I'm just
checking
why is that like that I don't like that
also I don't know why I'm
down here
is safe I like saving I don't know why I
came here and I don't know what's
happening and I don't remember going in
any Prosthetic Center oh yes I did isn't
that where all the
foreign
all right well this was a big waste of
time then all right moving back
whoa whoa whoa
[Applause]
oh hi bud
thank you
walking out full health
full stasis that's what I needed
all right I'm Gonna Save again because I
like saving all right cryolab need some
liquid nitrogen
that's all we need
that is all we need
why does this not seem familiar wait
what have I been wait am I in the right
wait a minute no this is not the right
way I was about to say this is not the
right way I don't know why I missed my
turn but apparently I did oh
but now I'm curious of where the cooling
pipes go now where do you go
where do you go I see liquid hydrogen
there it's a big old tube of it
that kind of what I'm looking for
oh oh
my God
zero gravity
that's the last time I deviated From the
Path there's no good reason to deviate
from the path it just ends in pain it
ends in pain and suffering and I don't
need either of those things I need
happiness and joy
and preferably sweet blessed silence
I'm back oh looks like they're all dead
huh maybe I should know personal disease
I'm just gonna know personals is you no
personal ease
no personalities
no personalies sorry no personally okay
still dead good
cryogenics lab hey that's what I needed
right I was running away from a big
spooky thing
right of course of course of course of
course
well I'm sure that uh that thing's gone
I'm sure it is
I'm sure it's gone it's never coming
back
therefore I don't need to worry about it
ever again
lab storage three
boy I wish
I really wish grab all the stuff first
then save
love it
hello
uh interesting
oh great well these are being used for
good purposes
great oh good
great
good
love what you've done with the place
really beautiful here
hey liquid nitrogen I got it
oh
it's almost worth losing my other
patients
but you
and Dr Brenner
delayed me enough
oh there you go
I have never
anything but courtesies
you say the same thing I can say I'm not
a [__] murderer speaking of courtesy
fixing the ishimura's inches
foreign
yes you win for an answer
I don't like what those things are
doubt even you can stop a convergence
effect fueled by the entire population
of universe
sinks to Earth it's all over
the humanity will be made all Mr Clark
with
I see
you've chosen your side
okay
good are you walking around with a nail
well hey there pal
hey what's up buddy
all right listen listen this ain't gonna
be fair you know and I'll tell you why
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why yeah oh shoot I almost had
you
almost whoa okay that is no need for
babies
all right hold on hold on hold on hold
on where are you well there's a little
too much happening here okay stop drop
roll okay here we go we're gonna try
that again stop drop and you're gonna
walk a little closer there buddy and
shove it oh God no no
like all right now I'm going for it get
out of the way you dumb baby
hit it oh God I'm amazing hey don't
hey don't
get stomped baby
oh going in the vents and scaled
oh baby scared without the big guy
out again
Isaac you okay
ah stop that hundred
the Mercer's gone
[Music]
you have to seal the captain's nest and
warn Hammond
okay I can feel the nest but I haven't
been able to reach Hammond since he went
to the crew deck I think our air quality
is falling fast if you've got the good
nitrogen we got a fake wanted it
each other reach him and Mercer
I don't think he's done yet
hmm
oh
well well well
that's the end of that chapter but what
is that amazing glowing thing in there
I guess we just
hydroponic translation is sealed off
you'll need another way there
take the tram back towards the hangar
then head to the Repair Station remember
where you took that broken tram car off
the tracks there's an access door in
there that'll take you to Hydroponics
well that's awfully convenient but we'll
have to find out if that's the truth or
not in the next video thank you
everybody so much for watching hope
you're enjoying Dead Space so far I
definitely am and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye